desantis takes aim at biden's new
ministry of truth during press
conference now here's a guy who's
standing up i don't know if the santos
will run if trump runs i think he said
he won't but
let's talk about what's going on joe
biden's ministry of truth speaking to
reporters in williston the desantis
started the discussion about the board
by saying he has he honestly thought it
was just a belated april fool's joke
they're actually going to create in the
department of homeland security a bureau
of disinformation it's basically a
ministry of truth what they want to do
is they want to be able to put out false
narratives without people being able to
speak out and fight back they want to be
able to say things like russian
collusion and perpetuate hoaxes and have
people like us be silenced and genseki
said that she believes the intent is to
stop disinformation how does the
government stop disinformation here's
the example i gave
ian what color is the sky
dark black tonight
depends on what time of day you ask uh
sheamus what color is this guy
i'm taking his answer what color is this
guy i'll go with blue ah we have two
different correct answers hold on the
sky is blue right aha but at night it's
black
ah but it's not really blue during the
day it's just a refraction of sunlight
it's actually black so depending on
which way you're looking it's that's
it's the six and the nine thing where
people are looking both ways the
government can use whatever
justification to claim something is fake
news and then eliminate it they
shouldn't be allowed to do that under
the first amendment i'm willing to bet
they get sued into oblivion and this
gets struck down by the supreme court oh
i think this i think this goes more back
to what was being discussed before
that's the whole idea of self-censoring
it it's not that they're going to come
out and put you in a gulag right under
the you know bureau of misinformation
what's going to end up happening is that
there's going to be a strong motivation
for people to not
go against whatever the government line
is like you you saw that nobody nobody
put any twitter facebook executive
instagram nobody put any of them in jail
over covet information they just did
enough threats
to where people self-censored i'm gonna
tell you exactly what it will be
open up your ears good friends because
let me predict the future
in one year one year's time we'll be in
the throes of a presidential primary
potentially too if joe biden is not
going to be running again he says he is
youtube will come out and say
any story in the news that goes against
the narrative from the bureau of
disinformation will be considered fake
news and removed from the platform
because we want to maintain integrity
we are turning to the experts at the
disinformation governance board to make
sure false narratives spread by russia
aren't allowed
and then we won't be able to share
certain stories because a story will
come out saying hunter biden punched a
baby and we'll be like look at this
video but the bureau of disinformation
will say that's not true that never
happened and then youtube will say
according to the experts of the bureau
for disinformation that didn't happen
and you posted fake news so we took it
down just like those experts from the
intelligence agencies who told us that
the russian or i'm sorry that the hunter
biden laptop story was just russian
disinformation you mean the woman who's
literally running the disinformation
governance board from fox news biden's
disinformation director referred to
hunter's laptop as a trump campaign
product and helped push disinformation
by claiming that intelligence officials
said it was a russian collusion hoax or
something yeah i mean it's horrific it's
exactly what we can expect from a regime
like this however i do agree with you
that the more serious problem is people
tend to self-censor and so look
i'm not the first to point this out but
if we had a media which was completely
bought sold and controlled by the
government we really wouldn't expect the
messaging to be any different than it
currently is they all hold the one
hegemonic narrative
they're gonna gaslight you and lie to
you and try to shut down any information
to the contrary and even when that
information gets out there which it
happens to from time to time because of
the internet and the fact that we have
widespread access to misinformation we
heard about hillary clinton's emails
we're hearing a little bit about what
might be going on behind the scenes at
twitter project veritas does a fantastic
job exposing political leaders and
organizations the left is sympathetic to
and yet even with that information they
just say that's a russian disinformation
or b a discredited conspiracy theory or
c you're a bigot if you repeat it and so
people shut up and don't say anything
right and so they don't really need this
ministry of truth to be honest project
project veritas puts out a video showing
a human being say something
malicious or nefarious and then these
fact checkers are like it was
deceptively edited
it's like but there's a video of them
doing it well the thing that i get
really worried about this we had a um we
had a bill someone brought where they
wanted to they wanted to incorporate a
class within public the public school
system that would help children identify
fake news and misinformation
right and and me and my colleagues
looking for i'm like this is like some
big brother crap right here oh no no
we're going to have a list of groups
that will come together and you're
looking at it's like oh it's the
virginia education association the
national education says i mean it's one
left-wing group after the next
determining helping these kids
differentiate between true information
and misinformation and that's the part
that scares me because so many of the
issues that we look at right now when
you look at
if you have eight hours a day with a
child from the moment they turn five and
enter kindergarten all the way through
middle school high school and then
college
and you have
essentially warmed them up to this idea
that oh yeah the government helps you
decide what the misinformation is then
you get to a point where they don't even
see it as censorship anymore this is
just another useful service that my
government is providing on my behalf
yeah
and we need to get a bunch i'll keep
going i'm sorry no that that that's the
part that is terrifying to me because
again
it's
this isn't crazy conspiratorial stuff
anymore when you actually have them
setting up this department within the
department of homeland security which is
designed to protect us through
anti-terrorism right
that's the part where no they are
preparing a narrative where if you have
a couple generations of this people just
start to assume this this is just normal
right yeah absolutely i think part of
the reason they're setting this up is
because they are panicking they see that
people are able to access this
information and so even though they've
repeatedly lied it's possible that
they're starting to get worried that
because they've lost their credibility
people are going to stop believing them
i would also say piggybacking on your
comments about the public school system
the fact that the government is sort of
left alone with everyone's children for
eight hours a day it's such a bizarre
societal shift that we almost never talk
about on the right that people are
expected to have their children educated
by complete strangers crazy that's
completely unprecedented historically
you wouldn't let someone who you didn't
know who you weren't at the very least
aware of their lifestyle choices let
alone someone you might admire enough to
allow them to form the mind of your
child have eight hours alone with them
per day and yet not only do we do so but
it is considered a right for teachers to
be able to have access to your children
in this way and even have secret
conversations with them about sexuality
that's disgusting what did joe biden say
he did that's true but what did he what
else did he do oh man i have no in what
you brought us up to the next schools
and kids oh he thinks that it's the
right of the teacher the the the your
children he's like when they're here
they're he's talking to the teachers
when he says it through yours i said i
freaking creepy i got a bunch of people
angry because i said i think a lot of
parents don't care about their kids
because they send them off to
institutionalized learning facilities
where they don't know the teachers and
then
just don't even know what their kids are
being told or taught don't that seems
crazy to me so maybe it's just my bias
because i was homeschooled when i was
little my mom she very much paid
attention to what we were what we were
learning and stuff like that and
actually helped teach us
and then my dad did as well so maybe i
see that like my parents cared about
what we were learning and they talked to
us
and i look at these parents where it's
like i'm in florida and my kid goes to
school and i got no idea what's
happening out there yeah why would
imagine if you took your kid went up to
a random house knocked in the door and
said can you watch my kid for the next
eight hours every day for the next 12
years
random person this is this is why this
is why i go back into the whole it's the
whole social conditioning of something
if if your parents went to public school
and then you went to public school and
now you have your kids and you send your
kids to public school this is just
something you do there's a certain
degree of social inertia with respect to
some of the decisions we make and we
think if it was good enough for my
parents good enough for me then it's
good enough for my kids without
recognizing that no the the window has
shifted a little bit with respect to
what they're talking about to your kids
because your kids might come home and
maybe they'll be able to do the math
that they were supposed to learn how to
do or maybe they'll be able to
understand some of the you know the
science they're supposed to be taught
but they're definitely going to
understand various left-wing concepts of
gender identity yep and whether it was
naive of the people at that time or
whether there was some legitimate reason
they believed that the public school
teachers who were going to be left alone
with their children or their children
were going to be left alone with had
values that were roughly similar to
their own so they weren't going to have
to worry about their child's mind being
malformed in some serious way but of
course that's not something that you can
ever trust strangers to not do and tim
you mentioned that people wouldn't go to
a stranger and say here have my kid for
eight hours today it's even worse than
that it's that stranger coming to you
and saying you have to give me your
child for eight hours it is my right
that's disgusting i heard consumerism
defined in a very interesting way a
couple of years ago and it was basically
that it is
the act of outsourcing more and more
things from the household and there are
a lot of things that it does make sense
to outsource but then there are certain
things that it's very strange to do that
with and i would say the education and
formation of your children is one of
them and yet we've done it in the most
like cynical capitalistic assembly line
sort of way that would make even the
most
sociopathic robber bear in blush and
it's completely championed by the left
back in the day i'm talking about a
thousand years ago or thereabouts if you
had the money you could send your kid to
be educated in venice italy by the most
intelligent scholars of the time that
was your choice if you didn't have money
maybe they would the king would come and
say your kid's coming with me or the kid
could be a swiss boarding school as well
yeah swiss boarding school you get sent
to it was like you know prestigious if
you knew the people they were gonna go
study with and you wanted them to learn
that kind of thing that's understandable
but today we have the option as humans
now in the united states we have the
option of where to send our kids so we
it but to like you said to give that up
so the higher power i think is lazy well
and i do think we've been indoctrinated
there there are well wealthy parents you
know people who know what's going on
are finding ways to keep their kids away
from these schools it's the regular
working class people who can't afford it
because you know you look at some what
the rich families do the ones who can
afford it at least they'll find private
schools
they'll talk about it or they'll send
their high school-age daughters off to
switzerland to a swiss boarding school
well again there's there's nothing
there's nothing wrong like again going
back to the whole capitalist thing
capitalism also about specialization and
division of labor we're all good at
different things and we find where it
fits so i i'm not we homeschool our
three kids right and my oldest is my
oldest is 19 so she's gone through the
whole process my i have a six-year-old
son 14 year old daughter and and here's
what we found
it wasn't that we just completely said
all right tina and i will be the only
ones educating our children at any point
no we we had co-ops that we went to we
had other things i mean my son and i
took a blacksmithing course together so
there was all kinds of ways that we
could reach out into our community and
find people that could educate our
children on things that were either you
know cool and unique and in line with
what they wanted to do or was something
that we couldn't do because bottom line
you get past fifth grade math i'm done
man i got i got nothing for you at this
point i don't know google it so
we we still have those resources we can
find the difference was is that when one
of my child was struggling with
something we could find the resource
that would help them and when one of my
child was excelling with something they
were able to go as far and fast as they
possibly could none of them had to sit
there and wait for 28 other kids
right or none of them had to deal with
some of the i love the socialization
like oh okay socialization my kids go to
you know educational events they go to
political events they go to sporting
events they go to community events so
they get plenty of socialization as
homeschoolers now yeah you're right they
don't go to an institution every year
where every once in a while they'll walk
in on two kids having sex in a middle
school bathroom so they don't get that
socialization right but that's the sort
of thing that's going on and this idea
that it's either
you have to be responsible for every
aspect of your child's education or
you send them to a government school
that's that's a false dichotomy it's not
an either or a proposition yeah i agree
but i also want to make another point
here
so you mentioned that there are a number
of ways that you actually can outsource
homeschooling and i agree that's
obviously very important but clearly
you're vetting the people out who you
end up leaving your child alone with and
that is the important difference between
a homeschool co-op and a public school
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you